of President Joe Biden has given his
first speech since announcing that he
will be running for re-election in 2024.
now failed former president Donald Trump
trump was trunk Trump or Trump was
massively triggered by Joe Biden's
announcement we'll get to that later
let's first start with a speech given by
Joe Biden now you all know Joe Biden's
not my favorite
I'm not like a Joe Biden you know
cheerleader but he seems significantly
energized by this announcement he spoke
yesterday at North America's Building
Trades Union legislative conference his
first speech since announcing the 2024
campaign
standing ovations energy going after the
magats let's take a listen
paying a lower tax rate than a
construction worker a schoolteacher a
firefighter a cop a nurse
it's wrong it's simply wrong
they should think I was making it up
and meanwhile guess what my mega
Republican friends in Congress are up to
the Speaker of the House went to Wall
Street
last week suppose use cuts and important
programs cut all discretionary spawning
by 22 percent
including ones I just named programs
millions of work in the middle class
Americans count on
at the same time he and his Maggie
Republican colleagues are pushing some
tax giveaways for the wealthiest
Americans and biggest corporations
they'd rather see kids and seniors
struggle with what they need
people on Medicaid lose their health
care veterans lose access to doctors
visits and that's part of it by the way
not a joke
then cut subsidies to Big Oil that made
200 billion dollars
big Pharma
and the wealthiest corporate
corporations
Ryan talk about raisins just stop the
subsidies
same old trickle-down dressed up in Maga
clothing
only worse all right so certainly we're
grading a little bit on a curve but for
the sort of level of energy that we
sometimes see from Joe Biden certainly
energized saying it is time to finish
the job the crowd chanting four more
years the reason come the New York Times
again it was the title of the article
it's not say President Biden appears
to be actually served that Trump had
promised
folks
we're not making this stuff up
hell
it's time to finish the job finish the
job
[Applause]
all right so listen I I'm not going to
pretend this was the most electrifying
moment from Joe Biden but the the point
here is
um the polling looks pretty okay for Joe
Biden and there are people who are
laughing this off I got emails from
saying David Joe Biden obviously can't
win re-election it's not obvious to me
uh it's not obvious to me at all oh but
the polls the polls were spot on in
2020.
um and you know we don't need to we
don't need to do this game at this point
in time but Joe Biden certainly seems
ready and uh we're going to see Trump's
reaction we're going to see the debate
schedule we're going to see all sorts of
different things but in the midst of it
we have to talk about the latest from
Chris Christie